The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Good afternoon.
Good afternoon.
I want to remind you that
a week from today
is the second exam.
The format is identical to
what you had, 50 multiple
choice questions; 30 from the
book, Chapters 5 to 7; 20 from
Sacks and the lectures;
short answers.
So talking about tests,
why do we have tests?
You live in a world of tests.
Everything from SATs to, on your
horizons, maybe GREs or
MCATs or LSATs.
So why do people have tests,
besides making it miserable to
be under 30?
It's the revenge of
the older people.
Why do people have tests?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: One of them
is just verify
that you know something.
And people will call it sort
of have you learned stuff?
And the test is meant
to be an estimate of
what have you learned?
But a second form of testing,
what people sometimes will
call high-stakes tests in a
slightly different way, are
ones about selection and
prediction, which sometimes
involve achievement or
aptitude, things
like SATs or GREs.
So achievements are meant to be
estimates of what you know,
advanced placement tests, how
much math you know or physics.
Content in a given area.
And sort of a broader sense
of aptitude, SATs or GREs.
Now, one thing that's different
about today's
lecture on intelligence, it'll
be a little similar when we do
personalities, up until now, to
a first approximation, most
of the time we've talked about
what we view as general
principles of the human mind
and brain across everybody.
How vision works across
everybody, memory across
everybody, thinking
across everybody.
And now, we're switching
to a domain.
And it doesn't have to be this
way, but this is the way the
world has done it, where
we emphasized
differences between people.
So when people take tests, it's
not to see that everybody
took the test.
What they're going to do is, you
get an A, or a B, or a C,
or you get a high SAT or a
medium SAT, and schools use
the differences to
think about you.
And so one question is, from an
empirical sense, are these
tests pretty good at
predicting things?
And the answer is
they're decent.
They're not terrific.
So the tests survive, like SATs
or GREs, because there's
correlations between these kinds
of tests before you get
to graduate school for example,
and how faculty rates
students or how productive
people are in terms of
research or as a graduate
student in this case, or the
GPAs, or things like that.
And the correlations are
about 0.3 to 0.4.
To give you an intuitive
sense, the correlations
between sex and height, whether
you're a man or a
woman and height,
is about 0.4.
So of course lots of women are
taller than lots of men.
On average, men are
taller than women.
It's a 0.4 correlation.
So this is in that range.
So tests are pretty
good predictors.
Everybody says that for things
like predicting college
performance or graduate school
performance, a combination of
tests and grades are better.
The difference is grades take
a lot of years to produce.
Tests are one traumatic
outing.
So tests are just a
part of our life
in selection processes.
So now what is intelligence?
And it's a loaded word.
I mean memory is kind
of a neutral word.
Attention is a neutral word.
Intelligence is a loaded word.
I mean nobody wants to be
low on intelligence.
And so psychologists have
come out of this way.
But it's kind of funny, because
there's not going to
be a really deep definition.
Maybe it's a lot of different
things and how they average up
or something like that.
But people have said well,
it's something about the
ability to solve problems, to
understand and learn complex
material, to adapt to the
environment, mental quickness.
Those are all senses you might
have of something that you
think of as intelligence
in a person.
But whether they're one thing,
many things, it's very hard to
pull that out.
And we don't know too much
about that really.
And also I want remind you of
something we talked about, but
it's especially important
in this field.
We talked about an experiment
versus correlations.
An experiment, you have to
have a dependent measure,
something you measure.
But critically and uniquely,
you have an independent
variable, something
that you vary.
That's what makes a study an
experiment, as opposed to a
correlation.
So studies of intelligence of
every kind are almost always
correlational and almost
never experimental.
That means they're always
subject to lots of
interpretation and many
factors in the world.
And that's very important
to keep in mind.
And again, they tend to focus on
variation in people, rather
than what is intelligence
itself.
And again, here's another
correlation
of height and weight.
That's a stronger correlation.
So where did intelligence
start with?
It's a fascinating story.
And by the way, let me tell
you the SAT story, on the
sidebar, for a moment.
So SATs, nowadays do people,
some people get ready a lot
for SATs by courses you take
and things like that?
I read about that.
When I took it, people weren't
that organized.
But getting into college wasn't
that competitive.
And the original goals of SATs
was what, do you know?
It's really interesting.
Because it ends up being the
thing, they say well, because
people who are maybe under more
supported circumstances,
more financially advantageous
circumstances, get more help
to get ready for the SAT.
Those things might amplify SAT
differences in a way that's
not really about the person
to start with.
The original goal of the SATs
was to have a national test
that was fair for everybody, so
that schools like Harvard,
for example, that tended to
admit the same kind of
students from the same
small set of
schools in the Northeast.
So now, we have a test for
everybody across the country.
And we can admit people on their
merit, rather than on
small, social connectivity
networks.
Does that make sense?
And yet, SATs are now viewed
as a suspicious
tool in that regard.
It was originally meant
to be democratizing.
It's like everybody in the
country takes the same test.
It's not whether you have a
connection through a network,
to our university.
IQs have the same story.
For good reasons, and we'll talk
about that, IQ tests and
interpretations of IQ don't
have a good history.
But the original goal was
pretty reasonable.
So in France in 1904, they began
universal elementary
education, that every
child goes to class.
And Alfred Binet, a physician,
wanted an objective way to
identify children who
needed extra help.
A perfectly good idea.
A child comes to school.
Some children are ready to go.
Some children need a lot of
extra help because they have a
difficulty.
So he developed a set of tests
where he probed many different
abilities, like copying a
drawing, repeating digits,
recognizing coins, explaining
why a statement
did not make sense.
They wanted to probe different
little areas of abilities, so
if a child is terrible at
something, or two things, the
teacher knows this child needs
some extra help to get going.
So that's a good use of
testing, I think by
everybody's criterion.
But then testing sort of
took off, IQ testing.
IQ stands for intelligence
quotient.
It's a test to give
typical children.
They give it often for the most
commonly used IQ tests,
at many different ages.
They'll test a large number
of individuals.
And they'll compare what
nowadays what they think of as
your mental age to your
chronological age.
So your chronological age is
how long you've lived.
And your mental age is how
well you score on a test.
The most famous IQ test, the
most widely used, takes about
two hours of testing.
It comes from David Wechsler,
the Wechsler Adult
Intelligence Scale.
One for children.
And within that test, what's
within that test?
Because when people talk about
tests I think, whatever kind
of test it is, it can only
about as good as the test
design itself, to the extent
that it's any good.
A ridiculous test is a
ridiculous test, even if
society gives it to you.
But tests can be better
than that.
So what is inside the most
widely used IQ tests,
especially in clinical
environments?
So let's talk about
one of them.
It has a bunch of
little tests.
One is vocabulary.
They ask you to define
words, similarities.
They'll ask you a series of
questions, like how are an
airplane and a car alike?
Very simple arithmetic
operations.
Digit spans, how many digits
can you remember.
Information, they'll give you
a series of questions, like
who was Martin Luther
King, Jr.?
Comprehension, they'll ask you
things about the world, like
why are there taxes and
things like that.
And you give an answer.
Somebody scribbles down
when you say.
And they score you.
You get two points
or one point.
We'll talk about that.
And then they add up these
scores in the subtests.
So in the nonverbal verbal
tests or the performance
tests, they'll show you a
picture with a thing missing.
Have you did that a kid?
I love those things.
What's missing in the picture
and stuff like that.
Blocks, they'll have you
rearrange them into various
geometric design.
Picture arrangement, you'll
get cartoon panels and you
have to put them in the correct
order to tell a story.
And they measure how accurately
and quickly you do
these things.
There's nothing amazing about
any of these things.
They're probing a variety
of little
abilities that you have.
And again, they will take the
mental age and chronological
age, divide it, multiply
it by 100.
And they'll standardize it, so
that 100 is the population
mean in the United States.
Other countries do these
things, as well.
Is that OK?
So I mean a test can only be
as possibly good as the
content of it.
And what it measures or doesn't
measure depends on the
specific conflict of it.
They'll scale the scores out,
so you get a normal
distribution, with a
peak in the middle.
The raw score is the
number you get.
The standardized one is
adjusted for your age.
And it's a pretty important
concept, because we'll come
back to this in a moment.
The raw score is your
actual score.
But then they adjust
it for your age.
Because you don't expect a
five-year-old to do as well as
a 15-year-old, to do as well
as peak 18 to 23-year-olds.
And then bad things happen
as you get older.
I'll tell you a bit of
them about that too.
2/3 of the people are at plus or
minus 1 standard deviation.
They set it for that.
More than two standard
deviations up or down, are
about 5% on either end of the
distribution of scores.
And they norm it by age.
Again, you don't expect a
six-year-old to do something.
But you get some funny things.
Not that you have to worry
about this in detail.
But it gives you a sense.
So imagine you're a
five-year-old and you take the
test, on the last day you're
a five-year-old.
Or imagine you have your
birthday today and
you're six years old.
By moving from five to six, from
Wednesday to Thursday,
you've moved up a year
for the scoring.
Because they go by
year, not by day.
So if you would have scored 120
on the IQ test yesterday,
when they say what should
you have scored for a
five-year-old, the very same
test, the next day,
you would score 100.
Now, that's the extreme case.
But you understand what
happens, right?
Because here's how
well you did.
That might have been
pretty good.
120 is above the average
for a five-year-old.
But the next day, if you're
a six-year-old, now for a
six-year-old, it's
just average.
So age has a big effect
on these things.
Here's something sad for aging,
but good for you.
Be smart now.
A 40-year-old who
scores average
would be a real undergrad.
If I score like you--
no, let me rephrase this.
If you were compared to a
40-year-old, you would have
100 IQ, you would
have a 230 IQ.
Because age knocks down
the score as well.
So things go up and
then things go
down, in this problem.
And usually they think of a
score below 70 as clinically
concerning.
And the top 2%, you get to join
Mensa and do whatever
Mensa people do.
Which I don't know exactly,
but it sounds interesting.
An important thing about tests
of any kind, are two huge
concepts, reliability
and validity.
So reliability refers to the
idea that if you were tested
more than once, you would
get the same score.
The better IQ tests
work a fair bit to
try to achieve that.
Validity is the deeper
question.
Does the test validly measure
what it's supposed to measure?
So if we had you flip a coin and
said that's your IQ, you'd
say, that's ridiculous.
That's not a valid test.
We could measure your height.
That would be extremely
reliable measure.
You'll have the same height
today as tomorrow, if we did a
decent job.
That wouldn't be a valid measure
of anything about any
mental ability, never mind
something like intelligence.
So those are two important
concepts in
testing, but very different.
Now, why do people think IQ
tests are interesting, besides
just this weird curiosity
about intelligence?
Because IQ tests correlate with
GPA in high school and
college, job success, salary,
stable marriages, staying out
of jail, and how
long you live.
Again, it's a correlation.
It could be many different
things.
The thing I want to talk you out
of is the idea that if you
have a 200 IQ today, you've got
something stored up that
will fend off disease.
It's not that, necessarily.
It's that there's lots of things
in your life that got
you to that score.
And all those things are likely
to persist in your
life: good health, support of
education, interest maybe in
taking on challenging tasks.
You had those before.
You had them while you
took the test.
You continue to have
them after.
Another way to think about it
though, which is both a plus
and minus, depending on how
you look at it, IQ scores
account for approximately
25% of the
variation on these things.
So that's not huge.
That means there's many, many,
many other factors, besides
whatever IQ is capturing.
But it's about as big a chunk
as you can get for a couple
hours of testing.
And we know that other things
like personality, variation,
education, culture, all those
things blend in on how a
person will do on all
these outcomes.
So I'm going to go
back and forth.
Because on the one hand, we
say there's a lot of stuff
besides IQ.
But IQ has some interestingness,
otherwise
nobody would talk about it.
And it would just disappear
from the world.
So on average, on average, what
does 15 IQ points mean?
So on average, a person with
100 IQ in the US will go to
high school and a year or two
in a community college.
On average, these are averages
over huge variety of people.
You get 15 more IQ points, and
on average, you're likely to
finish college and have
a white collar job.
Have 15 fewer points, and you're
not likely to complete
high school.
And you'd have to have a job
that doesn't require
educational background.
So 15 point on averages
correlate with things.
Here's another one, because
everybody in the end is a
little bit curious.
In your own life, how much of
what you're good at or not
good at, of any of us, comes
from our genes, from our
environment?
Where does that come from?
What are the things that
support us or limit us?
So here's one study that took
women from the same family.
So they're all sisters
from the same family.
They're trying to control a
little bit of the genetics,
because they share genes
within the family.
They're not twins.
And definitely shared
environment.
They're in the same household.
And within those families, they
look at the IQ scores.
So here's the average group,
above average, well above
average, a little below average,
a lot below average.
And they say that in these
women, all coming from the
same household, here's their
average income and here's the
average rate of illegitimate
births, which is one measure
that people think is kind of
a social, on average not a
desired outcome, to have a
child without a family
supporting.
It's not going to help a person
succeed in the world to
be a single mother.
And so you can see, the salary
pretty much moves with the IQ
on average.
And the rate of illegitimate
births pretty much
moves with that too.
So again, it's an average.
But there's some relationship
between these things.
Now, if you pick up the
newspaper today and read about
nuclear disasters in Japan and
problems in the Middle East
and other things like that, you
would say, it's hard to
say the world is getting
smarter.
But you may or may not be
surprised to hear of the
so-called Flynn effect.
This was kind of a surprise when
it was discovered, which
is basically this.
IQ scores, where they're
measured, go up around the
world all the time.
By IQ test scores, it's as if
the world is getting smarter
all the time, which is kind
of an optimistic thing.
Whether it's getting wiser
is a good question.
But by IQ score, smarter
all the time.
So that's hidden for many years,
because every few years
these tests get renormed
for the groups.
Does that makes sense?
So they're given again and
100 is the average.
And they're given again and
But if they ignore this
averaging and just say, across
these tests that only change a
little bit, some of them only
change a little bit, if we just
take the scores, look at
1930, 1940.
And it just keeps going up.
So Flynn is the person who
discovered that the world is
getting smarter by
raw IQ tests.
And one of tests they use, I'll
show you an example of
this, it's another widely
used test called Raven's
Progressive Matrices, IQs
go up about three
points every 10 years.
So that if you were born in
1930, a person would have an
IQ of 100, their child 108,
and their grandchild, 120,
with a standard deviation
higher.
So it's like smarter,
smarter, smarter.
I don't recommend to go home and
tell your parents that any
debate you have with them is
pointless, because you're
smarter than they are.
But if push comes to shove,
you can look up the Flynn
effect and have a discussion
about that.
So somebody who has an IQ today,
just flip it around.
If you have a 100, your
grandparent would
have a IQ of 82.
By this reasoning, people
in 1900 would have
a mean IQ of 70.
And nobody knows why it's going
up all over the world.
There's all kinds of
ideas about maybe
nutrition is going up.
Maybe reasoning abilities
are being pushed.
Maybe educational things.
I mean it's impossible
scientifically to know why,
because it's happening in such
a global, giant scale.
But some people have said, the
tests don't go up uniformly
across the tests.
Which gives us a hint about the
way the world is changing
and how intelligence tests in
some way become a barometer of
what mental abilities are
increasingly prized by societies.
So there's relatively small
gains across years in
vocabulary or general knowledge
or arithmetic.
Where there are large gains
are what you might call
abstract thinking tasks,
like similarities.
So let's focus on that
for a moment.
So a similarities question
might be like this.
In what way are dogs
and rabbits alike?
If you answer both mammals,
you get two points.
That's the best you can do.
And that's what we would call an
abstract or taxonomic one.
You're abstracting across
the two things.
Or you could give an answer
like, you use
dogs to hunt rabbits.
That's not a wrong answer.
That's considered a
one-point answer.
You kind of seem to know what a
dog is, you kind of seem to
know a rabbit.
But you didn't give the best
answer by this test criterion.
Because it's a functional
description of these things,
not a abstract, conceptual
one.
So let's think about different
societies, besides the Western
industrialized one that
we represent mostly.
In Liberia, they ask people to
sort baskets of food, tools,
containers, and clothing.
So most of us, Western educated
in a very broad
sense, would put the things of
food together, the things of
tools together.
Those are the abstract
categories.
The people from this tribe
put them in terms
of functional pairings.
They put the potato next to the
knife they use to peel the
potato, right?
And here's the fun thing
in this study.
They said, what would
a fool do with this?
And they said oh, well, a fool
would put all the food things
together and all the
utensils together.
But that's pointless to do that,
because what are you
going to do with all the food
things over here, when the
utensils are over here.
You understand?
It's what our society
emphasizes as a
useful way of thinking.
So it could be arbitrary.
But it's not arbitrarily
rewarded and prized in the
world of education, that
we live in here.
So intelligence tests attach
value at a specific time and
specific test.
Scores are changing over time.
Different cultures are valuing
different things.
It's constantly renormed.
And because of that, here's
another example of how the
renorming is.
It used to be for some number of
years, that 70 was used as
a cut-off for estimates of,
broadly speaking, mental
retardation.
And why that matters is that a
person for example would get
certain kinds of medical
services provided to them.
When a new version of the WISC,
of the Wechsler test,
came out in 1991, so a renormed
version, so that
means the scores are going up,
if every state in the country
had simultaneously used that
new test when it came out,
which they didn't quite, but
if they had, the number of
people rated as retarded,
diagnosed as retarded, would
have doubled in a single day.
Because the norms aren't
pushing the numbers up.
OK?
So the number of people scoring
very poorly would have
doubled in a single day because
of the renorming.
It's very important to realize
that all these things, what's
really in the test, what's
valued by a sort of society or
culture, and the norming things
are really influencing
a lot of how you get
to these numbers.
So ideas about intelligence,
roughly in this field, have
come out of what people call
psychometric analysis of subtests.
They give you the scatter
of tests.
And the thing that struck many
people is how for a given
individual, there's correlations
among the tests.
A person who does well on one
test, tends to do well on
another test, and tends to
do well on a third test.
And a researcher named Spearman
gave this correlation
among tests, the letter "g,"
the name g, to stand for
general intelligence, and "s"
for specific intelligence.
And since then, many people have
said well really is there
one broad sense of intelligence,
are there
multiple separate kinds
of intelligence?
And people debate that
in the field.
And probably somewhat the answer
is it depends what
you're measuring for and the
purpose of the measurement.
But a good one to look at,
because it's very clear, is
the difference between fluid and
crystallized intelligence.
So fluid intelligence is
what we think of as
novel problem solving.
You have a situation
you were never in
before, what do you do?
Crystallized intelligence
are facts you know,
information you know.
So here's the conceptual
idea that maybe general
intelligence is a thing.
And then it shows up on
different tests, with the
different specific
intelligences.
That's like maybe verbal
or arithmetic.
But let me show you the fluid
and crystallized one.
So the fluid one we said were
first mental processes that
apply for a novel situation.
And that declines a lot with
age and adulthood.
So these lines going down
here, I'm about here and
you're about here.
Who should be grading who in
this course, you might ask?
The only reason that I get to
grade you is because these
lines keep going up here.
This is how many
facts you know.
So the plus of living longer
is that you get
to know more stuff.
The risk of living longer is you
don't use it as flexibly
under novel situations.
So a pretty strong distinction,
at least with
aging, between so-called fluid
intelligence and crystallized
intelligence.
Here's another study of exactly
the same thing.
It's a striking ski slope of
decline in fluid intelligence.
Look at this, ernt, from 20
to 80, it just goes down
relentlessly.
But when it comes to
crystallized intelligence,
things like vocabulary, that
kind of hangs in there, until
you have some big
health problem.
So at least those two
kinds seem to
have a different basis.
And people have thought about
different ways to think about
intelligence.
And I'll just tell you that in
general you get positive
correlations among the tests.
And so often people think
about this general
intelligence.
The correlation among
the tests is
the best single predictor.
Now, there's lots of responses
to ideas about intelligence.
One of them is the study of
emotional intelligence.
Peter Salovey is the researcher
most involved in that.
And we know this in
everyday life.
We know smart people, what we
might call book smart people,
who seem unwise in how they
relate to people, how they
perceive emotions, how they
facilitate thought with
emotion, how they understand or
manage their emotions, how
they relate to other people.
And so it's common sense to
think of that as something
that varies across people.
It's very hard to
measure that.
I mean, part of the tyranny of
tests is what can be measured,
gets measured.
What's hard to measure,
is hard to measure.
It's very hard to measure, in
a laboratory, in an hour, a
person's emotional
intelligence.
People have tried.
It's just hard to do.
Here's another area that's
gotten a lot of attention,
from Howard Gardner
at Harvard.
Kind of fighting back against
this idea of a single form of
intelligence as captured by
g, the idea of multiple
intelligences.
And looking at things, the
associations in patients and
development.
That we can talk about
linguistic intelligence,
spatial intelligence, music
intelligence, bodily
intelligence.
Great athletes have great
bodily intelligence.
Intrapersonal or interpersonal,
it's kind of
like emotional.
Existential.
So he said, there's all these
different kinds of
intelligence.
And each person is a
profile of these.
You can be really strong in one,
and medium in another,
and not so strong in another.
The problem with this whole
approach is, yes, it's true
that people have a
huge variety of
facets of their humanity.
This whole course, I feel like
every lecture we do, we just
turn a person a little
bit to study another
facet of their humanity.
But it's hard as heck to
measure interpersonal
intelligence or naturalistic
intelligence.
Now, maybe somebody will figure
out how to do that.
It's just hard to measure those
things, even if it feels
like something conceptually
that's there.
So this idea, which has had a
lot of resonance to people not
liking very simple-minded ideas
of intelligence, very
unitary ones, it's still not
gained much traction in
practical use.
So let me talk a bit about some
of the things that people
have said, well, if we talk
about this intelligence, what
might be some mental mechanisms
or neural
mechanisms that support
or underlie it.
So some things that go with
it are mental speed.
And you know this, kind of
quickness of thought.
OK, not even big thoughts, just
quickness feels like it
helps a person solve problems.
So for example there's a
moderately high correlation
between IQ, complicated tests,
of all those tests, and how
quickly you push a button
when the light comes on.
Now, we never say, wow, Sally
or Fred is really smart.
They can push a button
when the light
comes on really fast.
Let's go to them and get the
answers for the problem set.
But that would go with the idea
that simply being fast is
kind of a useful thing for
acting on the world.
Or how quickly people decide
whether two lengths, two
lines, are the same length
or a different length.
Very simple thing, just speed.
And another idea is working
memory capacity.
How much information you can
hold in your head at any one
time that's relevant
to the problem or
task in front of you.
So people have tried to explore
these in certain ways.
And I'm going to talk to you
about a couple of brain
studies that have tried
to look at this.
So again, we talked last time
about frontal cortex and
different parts of it.
And especially the
dorsal-lateral prefrontal
cortex is involved
in thinking.
And so people have taken tasks
and said, what happens when
you think about them?
So here's one, an easy item
on the so-called Cattell
Culture-Fair Test.
So which of these things
goes into here.
There's harder ones.
Or here's a slightly adapted
version of the Raven's
Progressive Matrices.
I'll let you think about
that for a moment.
I don't remember which it is.
So you're told here's some
rows and columns.
One of these eight answers
logically fits in here.
And it's your job to figure
out which one.
Let's see.
How do we like--
three.
I like three too.
Does that three seem OK?
This is a medium-hard item
on this kind of a test.
And then they do these kind
of map of results.
This is what's fun about
the Raven's test, the
item you just saw.
Which is they sort of looked
at lots of other tests, so
specifically spatial tests,
specifically verbal tests,
specifically math tests.
And they said if we have to give
you one test only, one
test only, what test would best
predict your performance
on all the other tests?
And the answer is Raven's
or IQ tests like that.
So of course if I give you
a math test, that better
predicts your math
performance.
If I give you a verbal test,
that better predicts your
verbal performance.
If I gave you a spatial test,
that better predicts your
special performance.
But if I want to give you one
test that gives me the best
prediction of your performance
on other tests, it's things
like these IQ tests
that do that.
And that's just empirical.
That's not arguing about
values or what
intelligence is.
A lot of people who work in this
field, they don't even
care about these arguments.
They just say, I just want
a test that predicts.
It's your job, if you wanted
to figure out why it is.
It's the genes, environment,
education, whatever.
I just want a test
that predicts.
So from that perspective,
these tests
have a strong history.
And what turns on in the
brain when you solve
this kind of a task.
Well, the frontal
cortex a lot.
The parietal cortex.
But especially, frontal
cortex.
So it goes with our idea that
thinking is very much tied to
prefrontal cortical function.
Here's another example of a
study that said, let's compare
what happens in the brain when
you have test items that are
hard, which is the outlier one
here, that require a lot of g,
or items that are easy, that
require very little g.
Will up here in the brain, what
happens when you turn on
your g, so to speak?
And again, the prominent areas
tend to be, for both spatial
and verbal, prefrontal cortex.
One more.
the n-back task, we
use that a lot.
Where your job is,
letters come on.
And in this one, one-back, you
say, what do I see a letter
that's the same letter
as the one before?
So, for example--
two-back, sorry.
So you see, R, R, M, X, this
is two-back, because an M
occurred two items ago.
Three-backs are really hard.
Because the letters are going,
boom, boom, boom, boom.
And what's hard about it is,
the letter in front of you,
you have to say does it match
the one I saw three letters
previously, plus remember that,
because it's going to be
the target for the one that
comes three after.
It's hard.
I can tell you it's hard.
You can be smart.
It's pretty hard.
And for this task in general,
the harder it gets, the more
you turn on the dorsal-lateral
prefrontal cortex.
And so they did this test with
students in Washington St.
Louis, Louis, related it to
performance on the Raven's.
And sure enough in the brain,
it's again prefrontal cortex.
So a bunch of studies have found
all these tests involve
a fair bit of the brain.
But they seem to really draw
upon the capacities that you
and I have in prefrontal
cortex.
And one more note, in brain
imaging when we talk about
things, sometimes it's better
to have more activation and
sometimes less activation.
And you have to know the
behavior to know that.
So whenever you see somebody
saying oh, this person, this
group, or whatever, had more
brain activity or less brain
activity, you don't know until
you know the rest of the
behavior, whether more
is good or bad.
Sometimes when people get really
good at something, they
use less of their brain, because
they can do it so
efficiently.
So here's an example of people
with lower and higher IQ doing
an n-back task.
And you can see that the people
with lower IQ have much
more activation than the
people with higher IQ.
It's as if these people have
to use all their brain
resources to accomplish this.
And these people only
have to use some.
It's as if it were that.
So here comes one of the
classic topics of
the fate of a human.
How much is your genes at birth
and how much is the
environment that you're in.
And if we were really to
understand that in a deep,
deep scientific way, we would
know the genes are related to
intelligence; the experiential
factors in the world, family,
education, emotional support,
and so on; how they interact.
All those things, we know
practically nothing about.
I'll show you one
tiny example.
We know practically nothing
about them in
any depth at all.
So we mostly end up using twin
studies to make the best
estimates we can.
Which doesn't tell you
what the factors are.
It just tells you how much is
a twin who is identical more
or less like a twin
who is fraternal.
OK, we'll come back to that.
But I do want to tell you sort
of an exciting direction
that's slightly getting at the
genetic story of this.
So you may know, many
of you more
than I do, about genetics.
But single nucleotide
polymorphisms are DNA
variations.
These occur relatively
commonly.
They're estimated to make
up about 90% of
human genetic variation.
And they're constant from
generation to generation.
So people have studied a few
of these variations among
people and related them
to performance.
So let me remind you of
something from last lecture,
the Wisconsin Card
Sorting Task.
Where you sorted these cards
mysteriously and we said that
if you have a frontal lesion,
you do poorly on this task.
You get stuck with one kind of
problem solving or habit,
answer even when it's wrong,
in a new circumstance.
So what people have done is look
at one particular gene
that's related to this enzyme
that modulates dopamine
function in the prefrontal
cortex.
So it's a risk factor
for schizophrenia.
It metabolizes dopamine
in prefrontal cortex.
We vary with which version
of this gene we have.
And here's the performance
on the card sorting task.
And let me pick these.
These are healthy people.
If you have this version of the
gene or this pairing or
this pairing, your card sorting
task is going up.
So this is kind of amazing
that we're close to that,
where a single gene
is varying.
Now, the score doesn't
go up a lot.
It accounts a small percent
of the variance.
But it's one gene having an
identifiable correlation with
performance on a
demanding task.
And you can do this n-back
kind of task
we just talked about.
And then you can look in the
brain as people are performing
this, divided by which version
of this gene they have.
And what you get is more
activation in the people with
this complement, than
this complement.
Sort of consistent with the idea
they're working harder.
There's the same group of people
who are performing less
well in the card sorting task.
So there are some genes that
have been identified that are
associated with what we may call
broadly, intelligence.
But that one gene only accounts
for a tiny bit of the
overall score on these
kinds of things.
And we don't know much more
about it than that.
So how do people even
begin to think
about nature and nurture?
And I like to think about
this in two ways.
One way is narrowly IQ tests,
because there's been so much
work in that area.
But it's the deep question
of how do we get
to be who we are?
So again, they mostly look at
twin studies, so-called
behavioral genetics, and
estimated heritability, how
much of variation is
due to genetics.
And I'll come back to
this height thing.
But to give you a sense, height
is thought to be 90%
inheritable in the US.
Tall parents on average will
average will have taller kids.
Less tall parents,
less tall kids.
And in twin studies, they
contrast monozygotic twins,
twins that are identical or
have the same genes, with
dizygotic ones, who share some
genes, but not nearly as many.
Of course, they share the
same environment a lot.
Have you guys seen the two twins
talking to each other
video on YouTube?
If you haven't seen it,
it's kind of fun.
The two twins are babbling.
But they're so demonstrative,
it's as if they were talking
to each other in babble.
It's kind of fun, if
you haven't see it.
It's very cute.
Here is it again.
The fraternal twins and here's
the identical twins, before
they're born.
This has been studied
a fair bit.
Here's the correlations between
IQ scores and people
of varying relations.
So let's work down that list.
Unrelated persons,
reared together.
So perhaps an adopted
person and his or
her sibling or something.
They're correlated at
about what, 0.2.
Foster parent and child, it
goes up a little bit.
Parent and child living
together, so that's a
biological parent and child
living together, that goes up
a fair bit.
Brother and sister reared
apart, back down.
Brother and sister
reared together.
So you could look at this
as kind of shared genes.
And this might be something
like environment.
Does make sense?
Intuitively.
That's assuming there's no
interaction between genes and
the environment, which
we know must happen.
So when I do this I'm treating
them as if they were additive
and independent.
Everything we know about genes
and the environment are
tremendously interactive.
We just don't have insight
into that in any
deep way, in humans.
Here's the really
stunning one.
Identical twins reared apart,
70.7 correlation.
Identical twins reared apart.
That suggests a huge
influence of genes.
Identical twins reared
together, 90.9.
So this is the finding
that stunned people.
So look at identical
twins reared apart.
They're much more like each
other than a brother and
sister reared together, who
share all the same environment
of education, parental support,
and other things.
So I'm going to come
back to this.
But as best people can estimate,
and these might be
radically replaced as we deepen
our understanding of
the actual genes and the actual
environmental factors,
but people are estimating
it's about half
and half for IQ tests.
And we discussed the bit of
arbitrariness in that.
So about half and half.
Let me show you a couple of
environmental influences that
have been identified.
And the first two, one suspects
has to do on average
with something about the
healthiness of the environment
the child was born into.
The third one is kind of fun
just to talk about because you
may wonder if you have a sibling
or no sibling, what
does it mean that you were first
born, or second born, or
third born, at least
statistically.
So let's do the first two.
Here's breast feeding, 3,000
people were followed from
birth to young adulthood, who
had breast feeding, for at
least six months, correlated
with a five to
seven point IQ gain.
So we said, 15 points really
seems to mean something in
educational outcome.
So 5 to 7 is half of that.
So that's something.
So let's talk about
this for a minute.
You could say, and I can tell
you as a parent who fairly
recently had children, all the
mothers in the US that I know
were going like, I've got
to breast feed and
get my kid to MIT.
Two more months of breast
feeding and this kid could go
all the way to tenured
faculty.
I can tell you there's a lot of
pressure on mothers, if you
don't know this.
Not my mother.
But now mothers hear, do this
for your kid, do this for your
kid, do this for your kid,
because of results like these.
So one possibility is there's
something in breast milk.
That would be the
direct mechanism
that's making kids smarter.
Give me another possibility that
has nothing to do with
the breast milk?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Maybe mothers who
breast feed, also tend to be
mothers who are more nurturing
to their children.
PROFESSOR: It could be
more nurturing to
children in many ways.
They could be mothers who can
stay home and spend some time
with the children versus being
under very pressured economic
circumstances that
prohibit that.
It could be a lot of things.
Does that make sense?
We don't know.
Nobody has shown yet that it is
the breast milk that goes
into your brain and pushes up
your brain, in any sense.
It's just a correlation.
And of course, if you're a
parent, I'll do the breast
feeding and let the scientists
figure it out in the future.
Here's another one.
There's the birth weight.
So again, you could say
the same thing.
I mean certainly having very low
birth weight is a big risk
factor for lots of things.
But birth weight again goes
with many factors in the
environment that are supportive
for a healthy
pregnancy versus not.
So it doesn't mean that
it's the birth weight.
It could be all the other
things that were in the
environment during the
pregnancy, at birth, and
continue, on average, in the
environment of that child,
throughout their childhood
and young education.
Does that make sense?
If they're born in a very
unsupportive medical
environment, they might have
a low birth weight.
And unless their parents win
the lottery or something,
they're likely to be in a
difficult environment for all
their educational
years to come.
So people have tried to make
clear, because it's so easy to
get into sort of little mental
traps on genes versus
environment, how genetic
diversity affects
heritability.
So there's a couple different
ways to do it.
Let's do this one.
So imagine you had cloned
tomato plants.
That means they all have the
exact same genes in this
hypothetical example.
But somebody has poor soil,
somebody has good soil.
Well, you'll get big
differences.
And the heritability
will be zero.
Environment can have
huge influences.
But if you have genetically
diverse plants, then you're
going to have an interaction.
So some plants will do OK,
even in poor soil.
Some plants will do most
spectacularly in good soil and
less spectacularly alike.
Environment by genes'
interactions.
And you can see this in so
many different ways.
So here's one example.
So we said height is 90%
heritable within a society.
But Japanese men in the US, or
people with Japanese extract,
are three inches taller
than people in Japan.
So they still have whatever
Japanese genes are.
They have Japanese genes.
But they're in the US getting
the US diet of McDonald's.
And it's pushing them
up three inches.
Height is heritable.
But environment is a big
part of the story.
So it's just both.
Now, here's a fun study.
And a reason that if you're
a younger sibling and you
desperately want two IQ points,
you might knock off
your older sibling.
I don't recommend this.
This is tongue-in-cheek.
But it's kind of fun study,
just thinking about birth
order more in a fun way.
Well, look at the whole
thing, we're talking
about from 99 to 104.
So it's five points we're
talking there.
But in some countries, they sort
of test everybody going
into the military.
And I think this was
done in Denmark.
And what they said is.
These are all children.
These are the IQ scores.
And these are the IQ scores
that you would have.
But what happens if your
older sibling has
passed away, sadly.
You get those points.
And here's a person who
has an older sibling.
And the older sibling
passed away.
And they moved up
those points.
That is, if you're a younger
sibling, you have a few lower
IQ points, on average.
But kind of strikingly, if
your older sibling passes
away, sadly; you seem to get
those IQ points as you move up
the birth order.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is this if they pass
away before birth, or --?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Yeah, when they're young.
It's too late.
Sorry.
For all you in here, too late.
It's only a couple
points also.
But this got into Science,
because people are always
wondering about--
there's been a huge curiosity
about birth order
consequences.
But let's talk a little bit
about birth order again.
Because there's a second really
interesting point.
So here's Raven's score.
And here is if you're a lone
child, the second of two
children, the third of three,
the fourth of four, the eighth
of eight, to ninth of nine.
You can see the scores
keep going down.
It's not dramatic, but
larger families.
And you can have a million ideas
about why that would be.
About why it is the larger your
family and the further
you're down on the list, you
lose a few IQ points for every
sibling who's older.
So here's one idea from Robert
Zajonc, who's a very creative
psychologist.
We're not sure that
it's right.
But I think it's really
fun to think about.
So here is this idea.
He said, I'm going to make up
an idea, which is this.
The first born, maybe he is
exposed only to adults.
The adults are talking to them
about the views of the day and
all kinds of things.
The second born has two
adults, let's say
in a typical family.
But also has an older sibling.
So the intellectual environment
will be the
average of two adults
and a little child.
The next one, and so on.
So he said, you can do
a kind of a formula,
which is like this.
Pretend the two parents are
each 30 and you're born.
We'll call your family
intellectual stimulating
environment, 30.
Because we'll add up the ages
and divide by the number of
people in the family.
Does that make sense?
This is not meant to be
a real formula, just
a conceptual plan.
And then he said, now you have
the two parents and you have a
four-year-old sibling, because
you're the second born.
So now there's four of you.
We divide by 4.
And we'll say the average
intellectual thing in the
family is 16.
By the time the next child comes
along, a seven-year-old
sibling, three-year-old,
divide by five, and the
average intellectual
environment is 14.
Here's the idea.
On average, it's better for
a child to have lots of
interaction with a parent,
that with a little kid.
Because a parent will stimulate
you more than a
little kid, although a little
sibling might be a lot of fun.
But purely IQ land, two parents
talking to you about
stuff, is a more educational
environment than two parents
plus a sibling who is two
years older than you.
Because the two-year-old
can't help.
No matter how smart he or she
is, they can't talk with you
like an adult.
This is the thought.
And now, here's the really
fun observation.
And again, we don't really know
if this is exactly right.
But every year, if you're around
issues of education,
there's test scores that
different states have.
And the test scores go up.
And you have taken high-tests
tests right, in high schools
and grade schools and stuff.
If the test scores goes up,
everybody goes, oh, reelect us
because we're awesome
administration and our test
scores are going up.
We're doing everything right.
If the test scores go down, they
go oh, throw the bums out
of the administration.
Their kids are watching too
much MTV, turn off that
computer, and so on.
Everybody gets the
test scores.
And they figure out who's good
and who's bad, parents,
teachers, school systems,
politicians, whatever.
Zajonc says, and this is kind
of an interesting thought.
He says no, he can predict
whether scores will go up or
down simply by on average in a
given year, whether there are
more first borns, or second
borns, or third borns.
That if he just takes that
population average of every
kid, the moment they're born,
he can predict years later
where the scores go.
And so here's the
scores in Iowa.
Of the actual scores, they're
going up and down.
So you can imagine, scores
are going down.
Everybody's really upset about
kids who don't study, and
teachers who don't teach, and
parents who don't parent.
Scores are going up.
And the kids are awesome, the
teachers are awesome, the
parents are awesome.
Because that's who
gets the credit.
And he's saying, uh-uh.
This is my prediction here,
based simply on for a given
birth year, the average
number of older
children in your family.
That's it.
And look how well that tracks.
It's unbelievable.
So it just makes you rethink
that so often when we get
information about society of
what's going on, this may be
right or wrong.
But we don't really know
what's going on.
There's all kinds of huge things
out there in the world
that aren't the easiest things
to blame or give credit to.
So they're relatively small
differences, but they seem to
track interestingly in the
number of siblings you have
who are older than you.
And at the same time,
this idea of
parental exposure to language.
There's this widely cited study
from Hart and Risley.
So they recorded for each month,
for 2 and 1/2 years, a
heroic recording, one full hour
of every word spoken at
home between parents and
children in just 42 families.
But they categorized them
as high, medium, or low
socioeconomically.
So in terms of income
and education.
OK.
And they're recording
lots and lots of
conversations verbatim.
And they code and analyzed
every utterance in 1,300
transcripts of 30,000 pages.
The reason why this is not
done a lot, it's not very
glamorous work to do.
You can imagine sitting
down there.
But they're recording lots of
conversations at home in
families who are better off,
medium off, or poor.
And they're looking at what is
the conversation like, for an
hour a day.
And here's what they find.
That variation in children's
IQ and language abilities
related to the amount
that the parents
speak to their children.
And that the academic success by
age 8 or 9 or 10 is related
a lot to speech at 0 to 3.
Now again, you think causally.
Because you think, parents are
talking to you at 0 and 3.
And 9 and 10, you're doing
differential equations, causally.
No.
The parents that are talking
to you a lot, 0 to 3, are
talking to you at 4, 5, and
6 a lot, most of the time.
So if these things are not like,
you get an injection,
you're done.
Many of the factors that we
can measure, continue on
average, for most people
in their environment.
But it's very impressive how
the environment altogether
influences things.
By age 3, the cumulative
vocabulary is 1,100 words in a
professional family as a child,
750 in a working class,
and 500 in a welfare family.
And welfare families, 600 words
per hour, working class
750, professionals 2,153.
By age 3, the vocabulary used
by children in the high SES
homes, is larger than the
vocabulary used by parents in
the low SES.
By age 3, larger vocabulary.
This is just telling you the
incredible cumulative power of
strong environmental
influences.
Because it's unbelievably
multiplicative.
It's every day, all day long.
And if you're in an environment
that's supportive
or an environment that's not.
It's not one shot.
It's every day, multiply,
multiply, multiply.
300 words more per hour
for professional,
than the welfare family.
Extrapolate to a year.
A child in a professional family
hears 11 million words,
versus 3 million in
a welfare family.
And strong correlation with
IQ scores by age 9.
So very huge differences
in what children are
exposed to at home.
And they correlate highly
with these IQ things.
So the literature is that on
average, on average, the IQ
scores that children have around
9 or 10, correlate
pretty well with ones
they'll have for the
rest of their lives.
Before that, it extremely
jumps around.
We don't know why.
But that's they're finding.
By the time in 9 or 10, whatever
you have, on average
tends to hang in there.
If you're 100 at 10, you'll
tend to be 100 at 20.
If you're 120 at 10, you'll
tend to be 120 at 20.
Does that make sense?
So there's been a lot of
interest in evidence about
whether you can change
your IQ as an adult.
So here's one study that got a
lot of attention, because it
was kind of interesting
in that way.
So they did a complicated
task like this.
This was an n-back task.
Simultaneously you hear letters
and you see little
spatial locations like this.
And every time something matched
two items ago, you
would push a button.
So you're hearing them
at the same time.
And if you hear a letter
that was two letters
ago, you push a button.
Or same spatial location,
you push one.
It's pretty hard.
They took 34 adults.
They trained them from
eight to 19 days,
so less than a month.
Skipped weekends.
25 minutes a day.
It's only half an hour a day.
They train on this.
And then they tested them on
some of these widely used IQ
types of measures.
Here's their performance on
the task itself, getting
better and better.
OK, that's not surprising.
And the more they practiced,
the higher they got.
So if you practice really hard
at something, you get better
at doing it.
That's not the thing they
were interested in.
They were interested in this.
Here's the IQ scores before
they were trained.
The IQ scores.
They didn't practice
the IQ tests.
And here's the IQ
ones afterwards.
This is the control group,
who did nothing.
This is the group that did
the mental practice.
And you can see, they pushed
up their IQ scores.
Not a lot.
But it was only 20 minutes a
day for less than a month.
So these kinds of studies
really intrigued
people in two ways.
And the more training you
got, the more your
IQ score went up.
The more weeks you did this.
Because a), maybe we could push
up IQ scores, if that's
important to push up.
This is a big decision.
Even when you're an adult.
What if you did more than 20
minutes a day for three weeks.
And b), maybe we could push up
everybody's IQ score, who
needed help in that, with
the right kind of
training, at any age.
So a lot of interest in that.
So let me take a step now to
sort of harder topics.
Now, one of the reasons that
intelligence and IQ topics
have gotten appropriately lots
of concern is a terrible
history of racism and sexism
associated with IQ tests and
the way people use that to argue
basically inferiority of
groups, other than themselves.
So the US Immigration Act of
1924, the official government
talked about biologically
weak stocks.
At that time, they were focused
or prejudiced against
Italians and Jews from Europe.
Different societies, different
times, as you know,
tragically, had biases against
different groups in the world.
Unfortunately, it's part of
the world we live in.
And even though we know now with
certainty that we're all
almost identical genetically in
any practical sense across
racial groups, race remains a
powerful social category.
It's a very complicated topic.
The experience you've had, is
the experience you've had.
But we know it's a
social category.
People identify to a certain
extent with that.
They recognize other people
in that context.
We'll come back to that
later in the course.
But it's a sort of fact of life
that we often think of
ourselves as belonging to one
racial group or another and
somebody else as belonging to
one racial group or another.
So I'm going to focus on one
thing that's both troubled
people and led to bad things,
but has some interesting,
important aspects
to think about.
So in the US, when people
compare African American and
European American scores,
there's a gap of scores that
grows over time.
So in infancy, to the extent
you can test these kinds of
things, there's no difference.
By age 4, on average, people who
are European American will
tend to score about four
or five points
higher on IQ tests.
And as the goes up, it
continues to go up.
There's a gap on average.
This is a huge average.
It's across many people across
time, as people get
older in the US.
Now, we've strongly believed
for many, many reasons
empirically that this is an
environmental influence.
And here's one example of
many pieces of evidence.
So that children fathered, for
example, by Black America GIs
in Germany, brought up by German
mothers, have exactly
the same IQs as white
American GI
children and German mothers.
That is, in countries where
stereotypes were applied in
general, partly because there
wasn't a history of African
Americans in Germany at
that time, the IQ
scores are the same.
So we think it's overwhelmingly
evident that
it's an environmental effect.
But in the US, there's a lot
of relationship between, on
average, across the entire
country, on average, between
what group you're in
and average income.
So here's the average income a
few years ago, depending on
which group you identified
yourself as belonging to.
So we talked earlier about the
relationship between economic
comfort or stability or support
and things like the
number of words a parent can
speak to or it's time to speak
to their child.
And the habit seems to correlate
with all kinds of
advantages.
So here's an incredibly powerful
and important idea.
Claude Steele is a researcher
at Stanford, who I knew, who
has played a big part in this.
And here's the idea.
So it's called stereotype
threat.
It applies to all of us.
But in some ways depending on
the world we live in, some of
us can be more vulnerable than
others in certain situations.
Here's the idea.
So let me tell you the
experiment and then the
interpretation.
The experiment is that he'll
bring people in and give,
Claude or his students, black
and white participants,
college students.
And they say, it's a laboratory
experiment.
And they give them something
like an SAT test.
And the groups perform
just the same.
Stanford students, black and
white, perform just the same.
That's the one group.
Here comes the next group of
black and white students, who
are told we're going to give
you a test of intelligence.
Now, look what happens.
The scores of African
Americans go down.
And it doesn't even have to
be the phrase "test of
intelligence," you can have
people just tick off, on a
front page, what racial group
they belong to and you get
almost the same effect.
So what is this?
This is understood as stereotype
vulnerability.
That is, tragically in the US
there's a stereotype that
African Americans
are not as good
academically as white Americans.
It's a pernicious stereotype.
It's one we can decry morally
and say it's a bad thing.
But it's out there.
There's another area where
African Americans are thought
of as phenomenal by stereotype,
which is sports,
in this country.
It's a weird thing.
The idea is that knowledge of
these things, even if this is
your real performance, once that
thought enters your mind
that I'm doing something that
some people say I'm not going
to do such a good job at,
is enough to make you
underperform compared to
your true potential.
So the other area where this
has been studied a lot is
women and mathematics.
I think that's disappearing.
When I grew up, everybody was
worried that women weren't
given as good an academic
support as men
or girls and boys.
OK, it's reversed.
In my lifetime, it's reversed.
Because now, by every
criteria, women are
outperforming men in the US by
every criteria, at least
societally, the number who
finish school, your beginning
salaries, everything.
So now they're worried
that us boys are
really being left behind.
So these things change because
they're cultural inventions.
They're cultural inventions.
And cultural morays change.
And sometimes in good
ways, hopefully.
So stereotype threat is that
other's judgments or one's own
actions will confirm negative
stereotypes about one's group.
Oh, you should do badly on
something or you should do
well on something.
So they studied on women
on that, old people.
Athletic ability of course
runs the opposite.
The experiment was
kind of fun.
They had a very athletic African
American instructor
come up and start
doing push-ups.
And all the white guys started
to lapse in their push-ups.
They got tired really fast,
compared to an equally
athletic white trainer who
came up to the front.
Does that make sense?
It's whatever is the stereotype
you have in your
head, if you say OK, oh, oh, I'm
not supposed to do so good
in this, you underperform.
Not everybody, all the
time of course.
But enough that we have to
be concerned about that.
More for academic performance
probably than push-ups.
But who knows.
So here's this achievement
gap.
And different scores between
again, at age 13, between
whites and blacks in the United
States, which we know
shouldn't be there.
Many factors are in it.
A huge variation among
people, of course.
These are huge averages.
But one that everybody wants
to get rid of, in a just
society where everybody has
an equal opportunity.
So here's a result that's so
unbelievable, that if it
weren't for some subsequent
results, I wouldn't even show
it to you, even though it's
a well-done experiment.
But the message of it
seems so incredible.
So here's what they did.
In this well-controlled study
in Science, and there's been
some follow-ups that have
exactly done this.
So they took African American
students and white students.
And they had them take
these various tests.
But some of them, at the
beginning of the year, wrote
an affirmation.
They had to choose a value
from a list and write an
in-class essay about why
the chosen value is
important to you.
The controls chose a value
from those same lists and
wrote an in-class essay about
why the value might be
important for somebody else.
You're writing a one-time essay
about why something
matters to you or matters
to somebody else.
So obviously what matters to you
is more powerful for you.
And by just doing that, there's
a 40% reduction in the
African American students
in the study in
their achievement gap.
Their scores went up 40% because
they wrote one essay
at the beginning of the year
about why values are important
to them and related
to education.
One essay did that.
Unbelievable.
And just a reminder about how
much one's attitude incredibly
influences your performance.
You have a range of things
you can do it.
And what gets you to the top of
your range that's in you,
or the bottom of your range,
has a lot to do with
attitudes, that can be moved
around by a lot of things.
One essay overcame a tremendous
amount of the
concerns that on average,
African American students have
about academic achievement.
And it's not just that.
So in this course, you only get
a couple of tips of things
that are useful to
you for courses.
Here's one.
It's the same principle,
but it seems
to apply for everybody.
So here's the experiment, also
published in Science.
It's really cool.
So they brought in students.
And they said, look students
often are worried about how
they're going to do in a test,
especially if it's an area you
think you're not so good in.
So they had them take a test on
Gauss's modular arithmetic.
Here's the pre-test.
Everybody did about the same.
Then they said, OK now, they
have to create pressure.
Because of course if you take
a test in an experiment,
that's not pressured, right?
Pressure is the grade you're
going to get, whether it lets
you into medical school, whether
you get to become the
head of the American Medical
Association.
That's pressure, right?
So they say oh, here's what
we're going to do now.
We're going to give you another
test, everybody
scoring about the same.
But you can make a fair bit of
money with a partner who's
down the hall.
We should tell you that partner
has already done a
really good job on the second
version of the test.
So if you don't do well, you
don't get money and the
partner down the hall doesn't
get your money.
If you do well in the second
test you're about to take now,
then everybody wins.
So they're trying to make
you feel pressured.
On man, I want to
win the money.
Plus there's a guy down the hall
who already did well and
I'm going to let us down.
They're trying to
make you feel as
pressured as you might.
As much as they can in an
experiment, like you do in a
regular test, in a
regular course.
So trying to create pressure
and anxiety.
And then for 10 minutes, the
controls just sit there and
think about it.
Oh, I hope I don't
mess up now.
The pressure is on.
I hope I don't meet the person,
if I don't do a good
job, down the hall.
An expressive group wrote an
essay for 10 minutes about
their thoughts and feelings.
Oh, I wrote this.
This is a huge mistake.
This should be "better."
I'll fix it up.
Better, better, better.
I did it unrelated,
in writing.
So here's what happens.
The group that just sat
there did nothing.
Their performance doesn't--
let me get this right.
The performers that wrote the
expressive writing, their
score goes up.
Everybody else's
scores go down.
Because here, here's where
they're beginning.
Now, they get pressured.
And they perform less well.
They're choking.
The group that wrote
the essay, their
performance stays up.
And it's kind of ironic, because
a theme of comedy is
frequently when they tell you,
whatever you do, don't tell
somebody x.
And then my mistake,
you tell x.
Have you seen that
a comedy show?
So you could have thought, well
writing an essay about my
thoughts and feelings about how
much anxiety and pressure
I feel, is like the worst
thing you can do.
It's like, I don't
want face it.
I'd rather clear my mind.
But it turns out that when
people write this little essay
about the thoughts and feelings
about their anxiety,
their scores rise.
And if they don't write that
kind of an essay, the scores
fall, because you've introduced
here the stress and
anxiety that we think is a
part of regular testing.
Does that makes sense?
I'll fix the slide.
I'm sorry about the typo.
Is that OK?
I'm almost a little afraid to
give you advice, because
somebody will write an essay,
do bad on the physics test,
and say oh, this is terrible.
I would have gotten a A.
But it seems like writing a
little essay about your
thoughts and feelings actually
pushes scores up.
I mean that's the scientific
evidence.
But again, it's just a reminder
of how powerful
feelings and attitudes are,
whether they're in us or
visited on us by the world, in
how well we perform, within
the range of performance that
are within us to start with.
I have two more points.
So we talked a little bit about
entity versus growth.
You know people who believe
they're like, I'm only so good
at something.
I'm only so good at basketball,
I'm only so good
at math, I'm only so good at
programming, I'm only so good
of writing, or whatever, versus
people who say, the
harder I work, the
better I'll get.
And that pretty much, this work
from Carol Dweck, that
many people tend to go for
one thing or the other.
Is it are we born with
talent and that's
pretty much the deal?
Or the harder we work,
do we get more
talented at doing something?
And so this is the kind
of questionnaire.
And these are literally
questions, so she gives
students, you have a certain
amount of intelligence and you
really can't change it.
I strongly agree.
That's this trait model.
Or I disagree.
The harder I work, the
smarter I can be.
And what she did for example, is
give that kind of question
to students.
And then follow them in their
performance on a math course.
Here's the ones who believed
they could get better.
Here's the ones who said they
only have so much math ability
and intelligence.
And look at the ones who thought
they could get better,
got better.
So that seems like a really
good thing to have, is not
only the positive attitude.
But a real belief that the
harder the work, the smarter
you'll get.
Last two slides.
So finally, finally, finally.
And we've had a couple of
them, but almost none, a
longitudinal, random
assignment study.
Which doesn't sound hugely
exciting, but that's the best
science we can ever do.
Randomly assign people
to things.
And then follow them over time
to understand how life works.
So one of the famous studies is,
this is Perry Preschool.
So it followed into adulthood,
123 children from low SES
environments in Michigan.
And they were randomly divided,
randomly divided.
And there's no randomness
right, in life, mostly.
You're not randomly
given genes.
You're not randomly put
into a household.
It's always things are super
correlated with each other.
And it's very hard to
tease them apart.
But here they took kids who were
from poor families and
put them randomly
into two groups.
One group is a program group,
who received a high-quality
active learning preschool
program and home visits, to be
supportive as well.
So they got help at home
and help in preschool.
And a no-program group, who
didn't get any of these.
I can tell you that when you do
random assignment studies
in real life like this, some
people argue, I don't agreed
with this, that it's unethical,
because you should
help everybody all the time.
But if you don't do this,
you never figure
out what helps people.
OK It's a little bit
of a circular--
you can't figure out what
really helps people.
And then in a really rare
thing-- so it's random
assignment.
They followed them ages 3 to 11,
14 to 15, 19, 27, and 40.
They follow you through
most of your
childhood and adult life.
So what happens?
Here's their IQ scores?
Here's the program people
in red and the
no-program people in blue.
And you can see that for a few
years, they separate by IQ.
But by age 7, they're pretty
much the same.
And when these kind of data came
out, because of course
after the preschool, they
go back to their
regular local schools.
They're pretty much
the same schools.
So people, after that they said,
well Head Start is a
kind of a program to help kids
who are poor, get a head start
in education and support.
It's no good.
It doesn't do anything.
Because once they get back into
schools that not very
supportive, the benefits of
the program disappear.
You didn't do anything for the
kid, because unless you fix
everything in their lives, that
one year just doesn't
make a difference
in the long run.
So everybody said, Head Start
programs are just, sadly, a
waste of resources, because
they don't do anything for
these children over
the longer term.
But here's the remarkable
thing.
They kept following
these kids.
And here's what they found.
For example, in the number of
arrests, 36 had five or more
arrests in the program group.
But all the way up to 55, for
the no-program group.
That's a big difference, how
often you're arrested.
That's a big outcome in life.
Earning $20,000 or more at age
40, program group 60%;
no-program group, 40%.
Completed high school,
45% to 65%.
20% increase in completion of
high school, from one year of
help before kindergarten.
Basic achievement at
age 14, way up.
Willingness to do homework,
way up.
So what's that's telling
us is, IQ is a
pretty interesting thing.
And we've talked
a lot about it.
It is an interesting thing.
But there's something really
deep in the ways you can help
people, that make them
succeed in life.
Not get in trouble, avoid bad
things, make money, finish
school, do your work.
That one year of school changed
these kids for the
rest of their lives,
on average.
And imagine if you had done
two years or five years?
And IQ in this case doesn't
capture it at all.
There's something else in them
that changed, that made them
more resilient in life and
successful in the long run.
So there's a lot of pieces to
who does well and not well in
ways we wish for everybody.
And IQ is a piece
of that story.
But there's a lot of pieces.
So thanks very much.